こんにちは、Olivia Lanesだ。「実践で学ぶ量子コンピューティング」へようこそ。これは第2回、Quantum
circuitsだ。今日の講義ではいくつかのトピックを扱うが、以下の3つを理解して帰ってほしい。1つ目はIBM
量子コンピュータが実際にどういうものかだ。クラウド経由でジョブを送るとき、何をしているのかをざっくりイメージできるようになってもらいたい。
2つ目は、qubitとは何か、Primitivesとは何か、そしてそれらを使ってどうやってQuantum circuitを作成・実行するかだ。
また、利用可能なIBM Quantum processorの種類とその違いについても大まかに説明する。そして3つ目は、
大規模な実験を実行するために従う典型的なワークフローだ。これには最適なPrimitivesの選択が含まれる。
ユースケースに応じた問題のQuantum circuitへのマッピング、そしてエラー抑制と緩和の適用も含まれる。これらによって
これらのマシンからできる限り多くの性能を引き出せる。情報量が多いが、付いてきてほしい。
すぐにすべてをまとめて実際の例のコンテキストで説明するから。まずはqubitと実際のQuantum
ハードウェアについて簡単に話そう。実験科学者として言えるのは、これは本当に興味深いし、点と点をつなぐのに役立つということだ。
クラウドを通じて量子コンピュータにジョブが送られるとき、実際に何が起きているのかを視覚化できるようになる。使用する
processorは超伝導transmon qubitで構築されている。小型のIBM quantum processorはこんな見た目だ。
この小さな四角がqubit自体だ。このチップには合計5つある。transmon
自体はキャパシタであり、Josephson接合と呼ばれる非線形インダクタに並列接続された2枚の金属板で構成されている。
ただし、Josephson接合を見るにはさらにズームインする必要がある。それは2つの
超伝導金属の重なり合う層から作られており、2つのピースが重なって接触している部分がjunctionだ。Josephson
Junctionは、複数のエネルギー準位を持つ人工原子を作るために使える素子だ。そして
下位2つのエネルギー準位をqubit状態として分離する。ここのぐねぐねした線はマイクロ波共振器を表している。
基本的にはqubitに結合した2Dの伝送線路だ。gateをプログラムするとき、それは本質的に
高精度に較正されたマイクロ波パルスを選ぶことに相当する。そのパルスの特定の周波数・振幅・形状・持続時間が
qubitに特定の動作をさせる。マイクロ波パルスの命令はコンピュータからクラウドへ送られ、
次に室温制御エレクトロニクスによって読み取られ解釈される。それらはその命令を受け取って物理的に
パルスを生成する。マイクロ波パルスと呼ぶのは、すべてがマイクロ波周波数帯域に収まるからだ。
それは約1GHz付近だ。室温制御ボックスがパルスを生成した後、それらはケーブルを通って
希釈冷凍機に入り、最終的にQuantum chipへ到達する。信号はパッドのワイヤーボンドを通して共振器に入り、
次に伝送線路を流れてqubitへ届く。これは少し技術的だったかもしれないし、
これらの詳細はこれから先の理解に必須というわけではない。ただ、皆が間もなく操作しようとしている物理システムを
少なくともイメージできるようになってほしい。では、これらの量子コンピュータは実際にどこにあるのか？
IBMは世界中に数十台の量子コンピュータを持っており、最近フリートを
100 qubit以上のprocessorのみに更新した。前回の講義で述べたように、一部はIBMの
Quantum data center（ニューヨーク州北部）にある。これらのシステムはすべての人が使えるようクラウド上に展開されており、一部は
専用のオンプレミスシステムとして、動作に必要なすべてのエレクトロニクスを備えた形でパートナーを支援している。
IBM quantum networkのパートナー向けだ。次はQiskitについて話そう。QiskitはIBMのオープンソースのソフトウェア開発キットで、
量子コンピュータで動作するよう設計されている。これ以降はQiskit SDKと呼ぶ。Qiskit
エコシステムもある。これはQiskitのコア機能を拡張・補完するソフトウェア・チュートリアル・関数のコレクションだ。さらにQiskit
runtimeもある。これはQuantum Computingサービスおよびプログラミングモデルで、ユーザーがQiskit Primitivesを使って
Quantum workloadを効率的に設計・実行できるようにするものだ。Primitiveとは基本的に小さなビルディングブロックで、
より大きなcircuitやジョブを設計するために使える。最も重要な2つのPrimitivesは
samplerとestimatorだ。これらについてはすぐに詳しく説明する。まだQiskit SDKを
ダウンロード・インストールしていないなら、今すぐやるべきだ。Qiskit 1.0が最近リリースされ、これまで以上に高性能で
安定している。これから始める人にとっては最高のタイミングだ。すでにQiskitに慣れている人は
最新バージョンをダウンロードして再インストールする必要がある。Qiskitとqiskit runtimeのインストールにはpipを使い、
好みのウェブブラウザでJupyter notebookを通して実行することを推奨する。また
jupyter notebookまたはJupyter labもインストールする必要がある。まだの人はそちらも忘れずに。これらのツールはすべて無料で、
追加コストなしに自分のローカルマシンで使えるようになる。Qiskitはvisualization
オプションの依存関係を付けてインストールするように。Jupyterで動作しグラフを描けるようになる。また仮想Python環境のセットアップも必要で、
その方法はここにリンクされているQiskitのインストールページに説明がある。Qiskitに慣れて
実際の量子コンピュータでジョブを実行する準備ができたら、quantum.comに登録してIBM Quantum
APIトークンを作成する必要がある。そのリンクもここにある。詳しい手順については
ドキュメントページの説明に従うか、Qiskitのインストール動画を見ることもできる。
どちらも説明欄にリンクがある。さて、Quantum
circuitsについて話し始める準備がほぼできた。このコースの目的は100 qubit以上の規模でジョブを
実行するためのスケールアップ方法を教えることなので、まず全体的なワークフローを検討するのが最も建設的なアプローチだと思う。そして
典型的なQuantum Computingワークフローを理解する最も簡単な方法は、Qiskit patternsだ。Qiskit patternsはユーザーがQuantum
workloadをモジュール式のツールで特定のステップを実装して実行できるようにする概念的フレームワークだ。これによりQuantum Computingのタスクを
強力なヘテロジニアスコンピューティングインフラで実行できる。これらのステップはサービスとして実行でき、
リソース管理を組み込むことができる。これにより、新しい機能が開発されるにつれてシームレスな組み合わせが可能になる。
経験豊富なQiskitユーザーにはおなじみのメインステップを紹介する。最初のステップはmappingだ。このステップでは
興味のある一般的な問題をどうやってcircuitの形で量子コンピュータにマッピングするかを定式化する。
次はoptimizeだ。このステップではQiskit transpilerを使ってcircuitを実際の物理的なQuantum Hardware上にルーティングおよびレイアウトする。
これには個々のQuantum Gatesをシーケンスに変換することも含まれる。
ハードウェア上で実行される操作の最適化とgateのレイアウトの最適化も含まれる。次に
Qiskitランタイムのプリミティブを実行する。これはIBM量子ハードウェアへのインターフェースを提供し、transpileされたcircuitを実行できるようにする
このステップにはエラー抑制・緩和技術の使用も含まれており、これらはユーザーからほぼ抽象化されている。最後に後処理を行う
このステップでは量子プロセッサ自体のデータが処理され、元の問題に対する有用な結果がユーザーに提供される。基本的にこのステップは
取得したデータのさらなる分析を全て含んでいる。さて、量子の基盤について議論する準備が整った
プログラムの基盤となるのはquantum circuitだ。quantum circuitにはすでに慣れ親しんでいるかもしれないが、そうでない場合はまずレッスン
3のquantum circuitsを確認しておくといい。これは「量子情報と計算の理解」の一部で、下にリンクがある。ここでは
簡単な復習だけ行う。quantum circuitとは、量子gate、測定、そしてqubitを表すワイヤーで構成されたネットワークだ
quantum circuitは楽譜のように左から右へ読み進める。一番左から始まるTime Zeroから始まり、
仮想qubit、つまりまだ実際の物理qubitに割り当てられていないqubitは、上から下に向かって昇順にリストされる。circuitを設定したら
gateを追加できる。このHadamard gateのような単一qubit gateは、そのワイヤー上のqubitにのみ影響を与える。複数qubit
このCNOTのような複数qubit gateは、gateでつながれた2つ以上のqubitに影響する。この例では、qubit 1の状態が
qubit 0の状態によって変化する。全てのgateが適用された後、測定を実行できる
測定によって結果が古典レジスタに書き込まれる。circuitの特に重要な特性の一つが
その深さ（depth）だ。quantum circuitのdepthとは、circuitで定義された計算を完了するために並列実行が必要な量子gate層の最小数だ
明確にしておくと、quantum gateは共通のqubitを持たない場合は
並列に、つまり全く同時に実行できる。しかし2つ以上の
gateが同じqubitに作用する場合は並列実行できず、順番に実行するしかない。quantum gateは実行に時間がかかるため
circuitのdepthは量子コンピュータがcircuitを実行するのに必要な時間の大まかな指標となる
したがってcircuitのdepthを把握することは、そのcircuitが特定のデバイスで実行できるかどうかを判断するために重要だ
また、正確な結果が得られる可能性があるかどうかも分かる。次に量子プロセッサの選択について見ていこう。IBM
は最近100qubit以上を持つ新しいプロセッサ群を一斉にリリースした。quantum.comにログインすると
アクセスできるプロセッサを確認できる。プロセッサは全て鳥の名前が付けられており、異なるロゴは
異なる種類のプロセッサを表している。例えばこれらはEagleプロセッサを表し、このアイコンは
Heronだ。特定のプロセッサの名前は上部にも表示されており、全て都市名が付けられているが、
必ずしもそのプロセッサがその都市に物理的に設置されているわけではない。それらは単なる名前だ。qubit数、
EPPG、CLOPSも重要な指標として全てリストされている。それぞれについて説明しよう
qubitについてはかなり自明だ。qubitとは、その単一の量子プロセッサ（QPU）で利用可能なqubitの総数だ
EPPGとはErrors Per Layered Gateの略で、100 qubitの層状連鎖における平均gate処理エラーを測定する
基本的には小さければ小さいほどいい。CLOPSとはCircuit Layer Operations Per Secondの略で、
QPUが単位時間あたりに実行できる量子volumecircuitの層数（仮想circuitでの話）を測定する
数値が高いほど計算が速い。これは古典コンピューティングにおけるFLOPSに相当する。これらの
異なる指標は、興味のある特定のアプリケーション領域によって重要度が変わる。次に大まかなレベルで
quantum circuitへのマッピングについて議論しよう。最初のステップはマッピングステップで、本質的には「どのように
問題をquantum hardwareで実行できるquantum circuitに変換するか」という問いに答えるものだ。間違いなく
マッピングは難しい問題であり、活発な研究分野だ。計算上の
問題を解くのに役立つ量子gateの順序を導き出すこと自体が、最も難しい部分である場合もある。絶対確実な
成功を保証する方法は存在しないが、推奨されるガイドラインと既にマッピング方法が分かっている問題の例はある
最初のガイドラインは、古典コンピュータが得意とする作業はそちらに任せることだ。古典コンピュータにとって
簡単なテストは量子コンピュータの恩恵を受けられない可能性が高い。量子コンピュータは古典的に困難な問題のためにある
もちろん、Qiskitや量子コンピュータを使うのが初めてなら、計算上複雑な問題を探すことにこだわらなくていい。問題を小さく分解して
ユーティリティスケールのプロジェクトに直接取り組む前に対処方法を学んでいこう。次に、測定または理解したい
問題の結果を期待値問題またはサンプリング問題に変換しよう
ほとんどの問題の種類において、これは本質的にコスト関数の計算に対応する。コスト関数とは
問題固有の関数であり、最小化または最大化すべきものとして問題の目標を定義するもので、
その目標に対してトライアル状態や解がどれほどうまく機能しているかを確認するのに使える
この概念は化学、機械学習、金融、最適化などさまざまなアプリケーションに適用できる
また、使用するhardwareには特定のトポロジーがあることも念頭に置いておこう。接続されているqubitとそうでないqubitがある
最終的には問題をそのトポロジーを表すcircuitにマッピングする必要がある。IBM量子プロセッサは
heavy hexトポロジーと呼ばれるものを使用しており、これは本質的に六角格子でのqubit接続に相当する
これについては後でコースの中でさらに詳しく説明する。今のところ最も重要なのは、このステージには
練習が必要だということだ。問題だけでなく量子hardwareの能力についても深く理解する必要がある
後で具体的な例とユースケースを通して、これらをどのようにうまくバランスさせるかを見ていく
では、選択したhardwareに向けてcircuitを最適化する方法について議論しよう。最適化ステップの全体的な目標は
circuitの全ての仮想qubitを、プロセッサのトポロジー上の実際の物理qubitにマッピングすることだ
ゲームの名前はエラーをできる限り削減することだ。そのためにまずcircuitを効率よく
ルーティングしてレイアウトする必要がある。まず念頭に置いておくべきことは、全てのqubitが接続されているわけではなく、
チップ上では実際に遠く離れているものもある。そのため長距離の相互作用を減らすか排除する必要がある
できる限り。隣接するqubit間にswap gateの連鎖を適用することでqubit情報を移動させることができるが、
swap gateはコストがかかりエラーが起きやすいため、より良い方法があるかもしれない。次に、レイアウト
とルーティングは反復プロセスであり、circuitの仮想qubitを物理qubitに割り当てる
ハードウェアでこれを手動でやることもできるが、物理的な
qubitのレイアウトについておおよそのエラー率に基づいて推奨を出してくれるQiskitのツールも存在する。次に、同じqubitに作用する一連の1-qubit gateを
単一のgateにまとめることができる。また、不要なgateやgateの組み合わせを省けることもある。例えば
一部のgateの組み合わせはより単純な組み合わせに還元でき、さらにはgateの組み合わせが
単純な恒等演算子に等しくなることもあるため、それらを完全に除去できる。これはQiskit transpilerを使って自動的に行うことも、
gate単位で手動でやる正当な理由があって、より細かく
制御したい場合は手動で行うこともできる。circuit のレイアウト・ルーティング・gate数を手動またはQiskit transpilerで改善したら、
通常はすべてのgateのタイミングが意味をなすことを確認するためにcircuitを可視化したい。transpilerでフラグを立てることができる引数があって、
circuitのタイムラインを可視化し、すべてが期待通りに整列しているかを確認できる。では、エラー
抑制について話そう。エラー抑制とは、コンパイル時にcircuitを変換してエラーを最小化するさまざまな手法のことだ。
これはcircuitがすでに実行された後に行われるエラー軽減とは異なり、そちらについてはすぐ後で説明する。最も一般的な2つの形式の
エラー抑制としてダイナミカル・デカップリングとPauli twirlingを活用している。ここでは技術的な
詳細があるが、後で参照することも常にできる。最初のダイナミカル・デカップリングは、
合計すると恒等演算になる一連のgateを適用することで、qubitに影響するノイズの一部を
効果的にキャンセルするために使われる。例えばXXシーケンスのようなもので、その正味の効果は影響するノイズチャンネルをおおよそキャンセルすることだ。
Pauli twirlingはランダムなgateを挿入して平均ノイズを単純化する方法だ。このランダム性が
異なるエラーの影響が積み重なるのを防ぎ、ノイズを特性評価しやすくする。
この手法はエラー軽減技術の基礎にもなっており、後でそれについても議論する予定だ。
繰り返すが、ここには大量の情報があるが、すぐにすべてが頭に入らなくても心配しなくていい。幸いなことに、これの多くはQiskitを使って自動的に行える。
transpilerによるtranspilationはトリッキーな場合があるが、規模でのユーティリティを達成するためにtranspilationはとても重要なステップであり、
マスターして最良の結果を得るためには多くの試行錯誤が必要だ。ここで少し
Qiskit transpilerとその機能についてもう少し詳しく話す余談をしたい。とても高いレベルで説明し、詳細に入って
後ほど例を見ていく。一般的にtranspilationは、与えられた入力circuitを
特定の量子デバイスのトポロジーに合わせて書き直し、実行とノイズに対する耐性のためにcircuitを最適化するプロセスだ。また
与えられたcircuitを、選択した特定の量子プロセッサのbasis gateに書き直す。Qiskitには4つの
組み込みtranspilationパイプラインがあり、量子circuit最適化にすでに詳しくない限り、それらの1つを使うことを強くお勧めする。
組み込みパイプラインをデフォルトで使用するのがいい。transpilerにはデフォルトでこの6つのステップが含まれる：初期化、
レイアウト、ルーティング、変換、最適化、スケジューリング。初期化とは
circuitをbackendに埋め込む前に必要な最初のパスのことだ。これは通常、カスタム命令を展開し、circuitを1つおよび2つのqubit gateだけに変換することを含む。レイアウトステージは
circuitの仮想qubitをbackend上の物理qubitにマッピングするレイアウトを適用する。ルーティングはレイアウトが
適用された後に実行され、swap gateなどのgateを元のcircuitに挿入してbackendの
接続性に適合させる。4番目のステージは変換で、このステージではcircuit内のgateがターゲット
backendのbasis setに変換される。次は最適化で、このステージは特定のターゲット深度に達するなどの条件が満たされるまで
メイン最適化ループを繰り返し実行する。4つの異なる最適化
レベルから選択できる。最後はスケジューリングで、このステージはハードウェアを意識したスケジューリングパスのためのもので、
高いレベルではスケジューリングはqubit上のアイドル時間を考慮してcircuitに遅延を挿入するものと考えられる。
命令の実行間の話だ。言ったように、最適化レベルは0から3の範囲の4つがあり、
高い最適化レベルはより多くの時間と計算コストがかかるが、より良いcircuitが得られる可能性がある。
最適化レベル0はデバイス特性評価実験を目的としており、入力circuitを
ターゲットbackendの制約にマッピングするだけで最適化は行わない。最適化レベル3は
circuitを最適化するために最も多くのコストをかけるが、transpilerの最適化技術の多くは
ヒューリスティックに基づいているため、計算コストを多くかけても常に改善に
繋がるわけではない。
出力circuitの品質が向上するとは限らない。これにさらに興味があれば、Qiskitの
ドキュメントの下にリンクされているtranspilerページを確認してほしい。これで量子circuitの実際の実行について議論する準備ができた。
QiskitランタイムプリミティブはIBM Quantum ハードウェアへのインターフェースを提供し、エラー
抑制と軽減をユーザーから抽象化する。samplerプリミティブは準確率分布またはカウントを返し、
特定のビット列（0と1）を測定する可能性を表す。estimatorプリミティブは物理量に対応するオブザーバブルの期待値を返す。
もう少し詳しく言うと、samplerは量子デバイス上でcircuitを複数回実行し、各実行で測定を行い、確率
分布をそれらのビット列から構築する。実行回数（shots）が多いほど結果は正確になるが、
それには多くの時間と量子リソースが必要だ。具体的には、circuitで準備された状態を測定することで、
それぞれ可能な標準基底状態を得る確率を計算する。Qiskitの
estimatorは複雑な代数プロセスを使い、既知の固有基底を持つ他のオブザーバブルの組み合わせにオブザーバブルを分解して、実際の量子デバイス上で期待値を推定する。
プリミティブの内部で動いているのは、エラー軽減と呼ばれる手法だ。エラー軽減はこれらすべての包括的な用語であり、
実行時のデバイスノイズをモデル化することでcircuitエラーを低減する手法のことだ。
これは通常、モデルのトレーニングに関連する量子前処理オーバーヘッドと古典的な
生の結果のエラーを軽減するための生成モデルを使った後処理オーバーヘッドをもたらすが、この
オーバーヘッドと引き換えにはるかに正確な結果が得られる。エラー軽減のために実装できる複数の手法があり、
そのうちの3つについて詳しく説明する。ただし、これは
活発に研究されている分野であることに注意してほしい。
エラー軽減について3つをより詳しく説明していく予定だが、これは
活発な研究分野なので、新しい技術が発明され続け、古い技術も改善され続けるだろう。
レジリエンスレベルが上がると、コスト、つまりジョブの実行にかかる時間が増える。レジリエンスレベルゼロでは
transpilerはcircuitに何もしないと言ったが、レジリエンスレベル1からはtwirled
readout error extinction、略してT-Rexと呼ぶ手法が導入される。T-Rexはpoly twirlingを使って
ノイズを軽減する。これはすでに触れたことだが、非常に汎用的で効果的な技術だ。
直感的に言えば、ノイズをより規則的で扱いやすくするものだ。レジリエンスレベル2からは
zero noise extrapolation、略してZNEが導入される。これは最近大きな成果を上げている人気の技術だ。
ZNEの考え方は少し驚くかもしれない。実際に既存のノイズに
追加のノイズを乗せるんだ。しかしこうすることで、逆方向に外挿して
ノイズが少ない場合の結果を予測できる。これはいくつかの具体的な方法で実現できる。例えば
gateを引き伸ばして長くし、エラーが起きやすくするか、最終的にidentity演算になる
追加のgateを実行する。そうするとcircuitの機能は変わらないが、意図的により多くの
ノイズをサンプリングする。ただし、これは追跡したいすべてのcircuitと期待値に対して行う必要があるので
必要な時間という観点で非常にコストがかかることがわかる。ZNEの特定の一種を
probabilistic error amplification、略してPEAという。あるgateのノイズモデルを学習した後、PEAはそのノイズモデルから
エラーをサンプリングし、意図的にcircuitに注入する。先述のように、新しい
技術が次々と開発され続けており、より多くの技術が登場するにつれて実装されることが期待される。最後にもう一つ
error mitigationの形式について説明したい。probabilistic error cancellationと呼ばれるものだ。第三のレジリエンス
レベルではなく、PECはQiskitで手動でオンにする必要がある特別な機能だ。なぜなら計算リソースが
他のerror mitigation技術と比べてスケールしにくいからだ。まず
ノイズ学習またはノイズ特性評価のcircuitを実行することで、circuitに影響するノイズを学習する。
circuitの中にある2つのqubit gateの固有の層ごとに実行する。その結果をもとにノイズを
poly演算子の形で記述できる。これらのノイズ項がわかったら、circuitを修正して
実質的に逆のPECが組み込まれ、ノイズチャネルをキャンセルできるようにする。このプロセスはある意味で
ノイズキャンセリングヘッドフォンと似ている。ただし、ノイズを打ち消すこの方法はgateの数に対して
指数関数的に急速に増大する実行時間がかかる。だから非常に大きなcircuitには最良の選択ではないかもしれない。
これで最終段階、後処理に到達した。最終的に、うまくいってerror mitigation技術を適切に使えば
この図のように最終的な答えがシフトするのが見えるかもしれない。緩和されていない分布は
紫色で示されており、この線で示された真の期待値からかなり離れている。しかしerror mitigation適用後は
青色で示された緩和済みの分布が得られ、真の値にはるかに近いピークを示す。
これにはすべてコストがかかる。分散、つまり分布の幅が増加しているのが見えるが、
これは一般的に望ましくない。しかし何事にもトレードオフがある。幸い、これは
ショット数を増やすことで対処できる。分布が許容できる不確かさのレベルまで縮小する。以上がこの
レッスンの内容だ。次回はこれらのステップをすべてまとめて、実際の応用例に取り組む。
それまでにいくつか推奨することがある。まだの場合は
Qiskit 1.0をダウンロードしてセットアップしてほしい。またこの章の関連レッスンと
IBM Quantum learningプラットフォームの前のエピソードも確認できる。最後に、error mitigationについてさらに詳しく学びたい場合は
以下にリンクした多数のソースを参照してほしい。それでは次回また会おう。
[音楽]